i wanted to uh so
for the firs this is my first time at
atlanta and um
i had to go to magic city to try the hot
wings and i was i was extremely
disappointed
really yeah the wings were not uh you're
really supposed to get the lemon pepper
of course that's what i got though i got
11 peppers
i he said blue flame is way better oh
fun thing
the flame better number one number two
when i hear people getting magic city
food i don't really hear them get the
wings so much i didn't get like
everything else on that menu before
i got fried lobster tail that was fire
okay yeah that was that was smacking but
the wings were just
if you want wings in atlanta you gotta
hit the little corner spots bro you
gotta hit you like a little hood spider
you ever been to dc you know they have
you having like a little
carryout so you got the best chicken the
best mama sauce is the same thing is
here except we got like real ass hot
wings
i was gonna say you guys don't strike me
as like the biggest strip club
connoisseurs but
that's what you tripping too i'm
tripping because i'm so atlanta
okay so what what's what's what is like
the top three
what you right now right now
um for booty let's start with booty and
then we'll go food
a little my favorite okay um pretty face
magic city
and uh blue flying okay allure i've
heard of laura someone told me strokers
struggles yeah jaren benton is a sick
[ __ ] and took me to the clermont lounge
wow it's not that's not what it is
anymore it's been ginger fire it's like
that's like a big hotel yeah
no he did it on purpose he was like yo
i'm gonna take you to the spot it's
[ __ ] crazy bro
he's like dude it's so lit he's like he
was like just come with me for 20
minutes and that's funny
bro cause i he senior citizen dancers
that's crazy yeah that's that's why
you know a little laura got like the
best looking girls you gonna see but
like
they keep okay what about food strictly
food
we gotta go to cheetahs someone's told
me the cheetah [ __ ] like
she's all right she's like this food but
it's kind of like a
i heard that the the strip club side of
it's wack they're like it's not it's a
gentleman's club
because they're in there dancing the
nickel back it's super slow
of course and the girls are like just
slowly like
i heard they got a good
we went to this one random master club
in like ypsilanti michigan
and it was kind of like that we going
the auto strip let me be on tour we are
i probably could make a little
encyclopedia script club oh nice
i gotta put you on there's one in
phoenix called jaguars that jaguars
yeah it's it's um i think i heard i play
i passed by when i was in phoenix last
night
north carolina i haven't done north
carolina
yeah i do dc ain't gotta do miami no
miami
tootsies is my favorite yeah tootsies is
like
when my son was born oh [ __ ] like i was
about to say wait
wait when the water
glitter also tootsie's got that has
great food they do
yeah they got great fried fried lobster
tail with the with the seafood rice
man yeah definitely a vibe yeah yeah i
heard that the lamb chops at the cheetah
are
are where it's at i gotta let
like